ah
hmm lookbook Irian oh it's called be
careful what you wish for
written by RL Stein from the Goosebumps
series it's about a young girl who
obtains the ability to wish for anything
she wants and upon wishing for anything
she wants she realizes that that kind of
sucks and things start going really bad
huh
so you can say that she wished upon want
them like that no movie or not well if
they do it would probably really suck
wish upon is directed by the man behind
Mortal Kombat annihilation the butterfly
effect to wolves at the door and the
most recent Annabel uh what did you
think of the great film wish upon which
by the way I'm not even going to sum up
the plot because I just did I read a
goosebumps plot and it's essentially the
exact same plot just instead of meeting
a genie or something the girl gets a
wishing box on a cursed ancient Chinese
wishing box what did you think of wish
upon what did I think of what time did I
just check out I don't know you laughed
your ass off at the second death or so
the first one is that the first one well
not counting the earliest the opening
scene the basically what happens is the
girl makes wishes and people die as a
result of her wishes she gives what she
wants but at a price and we got a lot of
final destination scenes yes where
people are setting up a very elaborate
death scheme for for something to happen
it's still reminiscent a final
destination and yeah you're right I
laughed my ass off
yeah I left two actually at the end I
want to clap like yes that was so bad it
was good yeah um I thought the film was
a poor man's version of the possession
you seen it yeah you know 12 actually
liked that movie
it's kind of like they change it from
like the Jewish Dybbuk box to like this
Chinese box it has like a demon and
stuff but they don't really resolve that
so like I thought like whoa you know
they could use some other stuff with
this this film that could be like the
possession but it wasn't like the
possession had like atmosphere and like
very creepy music the music in this film
I'll let you speak of oh my god there
was a score right there was something
the score was just stock sound effects
for jump scares the music in this movie
is basically like the assemblage of
every electronic dance trance like pop
song you could find on now 68 at Walmart
yeah it was awful yeah it felt like it
went from being a really just boring
painful teen romance back to trying to
be scary with this this wish upon box
yeah and the two just didn't mix up it
tried so hard to reach and I think this
is what this only this moves only for
like middle school girls that maybe want
to go see Joey King or a scary film
that's not rated R so they get shoehorn
into this and that's the only
demographic they're going for this film
and so they really played it with this
this music like I pop in Iraq where high
school and it's all there's a slap fight
contest was always like cliched high
school stuff have seen a million times
it really was there setting up this
banner like early in the movie that she
worked all night the main protagonist
yeah Joey King her character Claire she
made this bow you remembered her name I
even know her but I had to look it up
and I'm okay I have to look it up yeah I
just like it it's joy can deliver yeah
she's setting up this banner she worked
on it for a week or whatever and this
the the the class bully some super
attractive girl on high and throws like
I'm a mocha latte on it or something and
she's like whoops I'm like oh my god is
this like 2001 bullies maybe more that
shit yeah oh then they break into a
catfight and everything that was that
was I think the moment there it was
ridiculous I'm like this is amazing
yeah what the fuck is going on right now
yeah I actually very early on this movie
realized
at this I could actually just make a
full-on hilarious ad about this movie
right now like I genuinely want to spoil
so much about it but since we're going
to be putting this up a day before it
comes out I'll be respectful to any one
of my viewers who really didn't want to
see more for the Planet of the Apes this
weekend and it's just hoping for wish
upon I'll be respectful to you to p5c is
what I procure five people but yeah
there are so many moments in this movie
that I was stifling laughter because I
didn't want to be that guy in the
theater like if anyone else is enjoying
it so there was a lot of work for the
entire runtime yeah like you said the
pre respectful audience for a horror
films yeah
so I understand completely what you're
doing is going to talk about the first
one the old guy does the second one
we're relocating others for the very
beginning there's an opening scene that
kind of sets up the main character's
motivation for like why she's guilty and
why she's sad and everything but the
first death that it's as a result of her
making a wish is hilarious now if you
saw by by man and you saw my review with
my buddy John flicking here we talked
about the deaths in that movie being
incredible just so funny this may be
tops it it's basically an older man
slipping in a bathtub and hitting his
head and then he gets trapped under the
faucet as the water falls onto his head
yeah they treated it like it was this
gigantic final destination scene this
really elaborate thing like the water
trickles here he slips on it here he
falls on the faucet in just the right
way then the hot water like sculpt his
forehead so he has trouble getting up
and he went awesome they could have just
shown him slip and cut and just like had
it be okay he died but they have to do
the camp yeah they have to elongate this
Depp scene and it was just it was a
comedy all senior citizens need life
alert help I'm falling and I can't get
up we're going to help ya
okay let's see oh I know what I wanna
say okay you should include that I
really Scott Oh Oh after his suicide his
wife was institutionalized she swore a
music box to destroy her family in the
last five years or so the box be
surfaced again in Cleveland okay these
films are we talk about music that
sounded like stock music well there's an
overhead shot of a city in this movie
yes yes we both notices it was like 360p
it's that uh yeah I might've been like
for eight years so it was definitely not
1080 or above it was blurry it was like
somebody went on 4k video downloader you
should have downloaded our YouTube clip
of that city
yeah and just threw it in the movie that
has to be not completed by the time it
goes out in the four days or whatever
the hell's like time I couldn't believe
that shit yeah yeah we both noticed that
it was like took a second we're like
what that's that's that's not footage it
wasn't even clear stock footage it was
like watching a show from the 80s that
has been upscaled to blu-ray yes where
all of the footage looks great and then
like the beach shots or the city shots
are terrible stock footage 1980s quality
of VHS converter that's the level of
craftsmanship that went into this movie
where they're fine with like a 360 p
city shot now if the movie comes out on
Friday and it looks better imitating
yeah paid the Boyle T's for the higher
quality version but I feel like at this
point I mean this is we're filming this
on Monday night I feel like at this
point it's probably final that it's done
like they're sending it to theaters now
that's unbelievable
speaking of you want to talk about the
free a little clip that they gave us for
the three why not actresses why not
yeah the the three actresses promoting
their their instagrams it was really
great it was really awkward like end it
movies about now don't say about the
movie oh yeah shut the fuck up I know I
know I do I really didn't know it was
about I mean the marketing for this film
you watch it like the trilogy like I
don't know about this movie but whore I
love for
or I have to go see it joy seems okay
for me oh why not and then yes did you
spy the movie even remotely scary
because I didn't find a single scene
suspenseful at all there might have been
one tense moment that's it that's the
only thing you can think of one it's
about as bad as Annabelle to be honest I
didn't any of that so oh it's bad man
and it's about as bad as that and it's
it's not as bad as Mortal Kombat
annihilation which is an atrocity and a
sin against humanity so but this is a
really stupid marketable horror movie
it's a movie that's exactly 90 minutes
long that has a soundtrack filled with
current pop trance hits a marketable
young star yes that has a lot of
followers yeah on Instagram
yeah followers huh yeah all over in its
room and and it's a bunch of jump scares
and it's got a pg-13 rating and it has a
central item that kids can get scared of
and talk about in the wish box yeah oh
no the box you know and of course
there's there's so many scenes where
they talk about its past history where
they do research on Google and learn
about the Bulls cliche oh I couldn't
believe it man and every time she made a
wish I'm like the first couple were just
joke wishes like you know okay I'll just
joke I'll hold this thing and make a
wish and they came true and for like the
first two or three she was a little
curious but like I think anyone else
would be like okay this thing's real by
the time the most popular guy in school
you're crushing on instantly likes you
when you want him to the very next
morning yeah I think that's a good clue
that maybe there's something a little
more going on with this wish box after
you wish for that to happen but of
course and then as people continue to
die she has the opportunity now to make
actual good wishes like world peace or
you know world hunger or things that
would actually improve the planet nope
all still selfish shit even one of her
friends it's like why aren't you wishing
for something like world peace inside
like she's crying and and just getting
all flustered about it he raids bitch
something like that yeah I just I felt
she was such a really terrible lead
character where I'm
not ragging on the acting but the
character itself and the way the
character was crafted in the script
there's really nothing she has a past
and something happened once yeah that's
it
yeah they only played that up one time
thought it was really well besides that
and yeah back to it being not scary it's
just one of those movies where from
sequence to sequence the sound drains
from it and then all of a sudden oh
there's a little 40min here hold on I
have to fucking capture wait wait one
minute what equipment okay
let's take pleasure in gutting new bar
bye-bye
I caught a book on it's all good suck it
yeah all right we can continue sorry
okay yeah sorry it's kind of just uh
like knock off Pokemon go I don't want
to like really capture on the craze
that's going on a mobile game I can say
it like unlikely tell me if tell me
about it do you capture demons
oh yeah it's kinda like Pokemon go um
straight-up ripoff but I can't pay the
rights like Nintendo or something to
make another game I think I'm just you
know go with that Oh II actually shit
that wasn't a who'll be totaled yeah it
really wasn't one God every time that
girl pulled out that app and started
looking for for demons to slay I'm like
it's like in the very beginning of the
movie when she was like oh wow I think
what's malformed Mary is that the
character name she's malformed Mary was
some demon that is in this Pokemon
little repo whoa I think she's at the
school I'm trying to capture her as soon
as they had like an entire sequence
dedicated to that app I'm like okay it's
not a real app so far as I know so it's
not product placement so this must come
back later in the movie and of course it
does it's like a major plot device to
get that character to go somewhere by
ourselves yes my god dude like the
writing for this movie look I mean I
don't like ragging on people in my
reviews and stuff and I'm not gonna like
but fuck it's so bad like yeah it's this
is like the funniest comedy I've seen so
far this year it really is it's
entertainment I laughed my ass off man
yeah it was the execution was funny and
the basis the writing funny I guess
one of the reasons the deaths are so
funny is because they didn't go for the
are so there's no blood and they had to
cut away from every really violent or
graphic moment really quickly so you got
you know fast inserts of things
happening there's a scene in this movie
where someone takes their own life
the next morning there's an ambulance
it's like 10 seconds and the girls like
and it's done they never talked about it
again ever
yeah it's simply done random
I remember you tell me about our talking
is very better about that moment you
notice the color correction change from
like seen won the prologue whatever to
like the rest of movie also just like it
just drained everything like yes the
fuck is this the century of that shit
yeah it looked really bad and then she
makes a wish at one point and the
saturation level comes up yeah yeah so
basically they were saying like when
she's feeling bad the Scimitar fee is
very dispatcher ated in gray when she's
feeling happy it's warm and bright and
that's the creativity behind the
cinematography in wish upon its July you
know this is a weekend the war for the
Planet of the Apes is coming out and
this movie this is a January movie as
far as I'm concerned it's January and
for some reason it's it's out in July in
the middle of summer this is absolutely
a January movie but it's basically
thrown in the summer so that as you said
middle schoolers can can go and get a
perfect Yemen set up and yeah I mean and
nothing against Little Scholars I was
one once we all are that way I might
skip it now here we just skip ties yeah
this movie is designed for the type of
crowd that just wants to go to a movie
and have those types of pg-13 scares
that don't really do anything but jolt
them for a second this movie wasn't
scary
the acting I thought was way over the
top there's a lot of scenes where where
Joey King really really went for it and
as you said we talked about on the way
home yeah it'd have been the direction
yes what the sy I say yeah there's one
specific scene that's all one take where
she has started to kind of lose her mind
and she's becoming obsessed with this
with this wish box the film doesn't
really sell her psychosis it doesn't
really give you a reason for her to care
that much about having it in her
possession at all times because it gets
to that point for her character Rio
needs it all the time
but it felt so abrupt because like one
scene she's like me to get rid of it
they try to burn it they try to smash it
the very next like five minutes later
she is losing her mind about not having
it
yeah and they just didn't really sell
that well in the movie it comes off to
me like a almost like a romantic comedy
with jump-scare elements and none of it
works yeah I can see that it's good way
to put it like you said this is a July
film but they've had success with past
ghost films like the conjuring I've been
in like August I think like sometimes
they have August of template you want
getting right before October because
October all the shit comes out right so
sometimes the late I think would come to
me like a shit ton of money so yeah I
think conjuring 2 is by like August or
something they were really successful
very good good but but maybe they
thought putting it in like late summer
ish would it help them out like oh we
saw this trend back in the day just make
we should plot yeah clearly we didn't
really like this movie I'm going to give
wish upon and F yep a one on IMDB
doesn't like a two or three ish but then
again just giving one oh fuck it this
movie man thank you for joining me in
this review though thank you for having
me it's been fun being in the presence
of the Terminator and the predator and
alien we got turned our clothes over
there I hope you guys can see that yeah
it's very good shit cube I'm in presence
of well I'm going to go back to reading
the pretreatment for this movie okay
oh Moodle class is trivial